welcome back okay so we've been talking
about the use of evolutionary algorithms
genetic algorithms to tune control laws
so this is in the broader framework of
what we're calling machine learning
control or the use of data driven
optimization to directly find and
optimize good control laws to control
some complex dynamical system in the
last few videos we've talked about how
to use genetic algorithms what they are
and how to use them to tune a PID
control law in general I want us to be
thinking genetic algorithms optimize the
parameters of known structures so for
example I lock in that I'm going to use
a PID control law then I can use a
genetic algorithm to tune the parameters
of that known structure okay and so
genetic algorithms are very useful for
four parameter identification when you
have a fixed structure but in many
control problems of interest I don't
actually know what the structure of the
control law I want to use I don't know
if I want a PID control law or some kind
of a column and filter like I just don't
know what the actual even structure of
the control law is that I want and so
it's not as simple as a parameter
optimization so what I'm going to tell
you about now is genetic programming
control it sounds very similar but
instead of genetic algorithms we're
using something called genetic
programming which is considerably more
machinery and what this does is it
simultaneously learns the structure and
parameters of an effective control law
and so you can read more about this in a
book by Tomas Terry a myself and Barrett
Nowak or the Springer book from 2016
called machine learning control where we
essentially developed this theory of how
to use genetic programming to design
effective control laws and then also how
do we apply this to turbulent control
experiments okay but the basic idea here
is maybe I don't know the structure of
my control law so I have to learn the
structure of what control structures are
actually effective and so I need these
kind of bigger machinery of genetic
programming okay so I'm gonna walk you
through genetic programming just like
genetic algorithms
is a much bigger theory than just
applying it to control systems so people
have been using genetic programming for
decades to design programs that write
new programs software that write
software and things like that all kinds
of interesting applications of genetic
programming I'm going to walk you
through kind of the guts of how genetic
programming works but in the context of
how we would use it for control and so
here what we're going to do is we're
going to define this the structure of a
control law there are some sensors why
these are my measurements of my system
and I have some sensors and maybe some
constants some numbers that I get to use
and I'm going to define my actuation
signal as this nested function tree
where the leaves are sensors in
constants and then there are these
function operations that compositionally
give me some some u equals f of of Y and
so in this case it's always a little
dangerous to do this live but I'm just
going to write down what this is so here
you can interpret this as u equals y1
plus c3 times c1 plus y2 okay so it's a
little dim I hope you can see that this
y2
okay so basically I can interpret this
tree structure as the control law u
equals y1 plus c y1 plus c3 times c1
plus y2 okay and that is a candidate
control law that I would then run on an
experiment and see how effective it was
and I'd get an objective function and
some fitness and I could compare 15 or a
thousand different control laws and see
which ones are more effective okay so
this is just a way of parameterizing a
generic function U of Y okay and it's
very flexible so this function tree this
this recursive tree composition of
functions is extremely flexible flexible
to take your sensor measurements and
determine what combination of those
gives me a good actuation strategy
okay now interestingly people have also
used this strategy too not just to
design a control law but also for system
identification to get the X dot equals f
of X people have used these genetic
programming structures to identify
dynamical systems models so bond guard
and Lipson and Schmidt and libsyn have
done genetic programming to identify
governing laws of physical systems in
2007 and 2009 in PNAS and in science
great papers you should definitely read
them that's how they use genetic
programming for for model identification
we're gonna be focusing our effort on
genetic programming for control okay
okay so that's the basic idea you have a
control law and you evaluate each of
those control laws so I might start with
an initial generation of a hundred of
these things randomly generated I run
them all in my experiment and I see
which one gives me good performance
which one gives me bad performance and
then just like in genetic algorithms I
had these genetic operations to get
future generations so one operation is
crossover so I take two good performing
individuals here and I pick some portion
of DNA from each of them and I just
swapped them okay so this little branch
here gets snipped and this little branch
gets snipped and I just swapped them so
now this guy has the blue group and this
guy has the red group okay so that's
this genetic crossover and it's known to
have this exploitative property that if
both of these are good I'm going to try
and perturb these and permute these to
get to exploit the favorable properties
of both of these now it doesn't always
work but sometimes swapping these will
give you even better performance in the
children okay I also have a mutation
effect where I can take some some random
segments of this function tree and just
snip it off and replace it with a
randomly generated new subtree that's
mutation this has the effect of
exploring your parameter space more
trying new things that you hadn't tried
before and then as as before you have
this replication so if a control law is
good enough maybe I just copy it to the
next generation directly
so that I don't lose that good
information okay so this is how genetic
programming works in general and as
before you have to pick these basic
probabilities of probabilities of
replication mutation and crossover in
this case I've chosen crossover at 70%
replication at 10% and mutation at 20%
but you can kind of play with those
numbers you know I you can move this
point and change the volume of these
triangles to get more crossover or more
mutation and or more replication and you
know there's kind of a lot of theory
that's got in to how to design how did
how to tweak these parameters to get the
best convergence how big of an
additional population and how many
generations all of that
okay so huge business genetic
programming this was introduced by by
Koza and soco's is a super interesting
interesting person you should read about
about his introduction of genetic
programming and kind of how he used this
throughout his career so a very
interesting story but this goes back
decades and way before it was used for
control of turbulent systems okay those
are the basic genetic algorithms that
you can then use to tweak these control
laws and try to refine them over
successive generations and what we're
what will then do is we have some
dynamical system maybe this is an
experiment or a simulation or something
where I can test control laws and I have
it here written down as a dynamical
system with an actual F but in general
this is a black box experiment and you
don't really have a good model for it
but you can control it and you can
measure it and you can measure in
particular this cost function this high
level objective in the case of fluids
that might be increasing lift or
decreasing drag or increase in mixing so
I have this black box experiment and
what I can do is I can write down a
bunch of control laws and try them and
try them and try them so I'll run this
experiment 30 seconds later I get a
really really bad J value that was a
terrible control law so then I run
another control law 30 seconds later in
the experiment I find out that was a
great control out really low J and so on
I can run a hundred of these things over
the course of an hour
maybe and then I use those genetic those
genetic operations of mutation crossover
and replication to design new
generations and iteratively refine this
control law until it's more and more
effective at controlling this dynamical
system okay now I will say that this
this control law structure there's a lot
more machinery that goes into actually
making these than a simple genetic
algorithm you have to write this kind of
compositional logic to handle these
recursive function trees and that
there's a little bit of programming
overhead to make this this
infrastructure so a lot of people do
this in recursive languages like Lisp or
scheme because it's much more natural to
write these recursive function calls in
a recursive language okay but oftentimes
for really hard control problems where
no known control structure has worked in
the past
you need this extra flexibility of
tweaking the fundamental structure of
the control law itself so something else
to point out you'll notice that this is
an instantaneous control law the
actuation signal is instantaneously
responding to this particular
instantaneous sensor measurements and
constants and that's a little strange
because we know from the control
bootcamp for example that if I have
limited measurements that don't measure
the full state of my system and in a
high dimensional example like a fluid
flow it's very unlikely I'm measuring
everything then I might need a calm and
filter to estimate the full state of my
system for effective control so it's
pretty surprising that you can get such
good performance with this instantaneous
sensor feedback and actually if you
think that that instantaneous sensor
feedback is not enough you can augment
these functions with transfer functions
so instead of just plus and times and
divide I can also have transfer
functions like you know integrate this
time history with this kernel and so
that can start to approximate these
calman filter ideas where now my my-y
measurements are getting integrated in
time into these these time filter
functions okay so you can augment this
picture with with filter functions we've
done that for fluids and it seems like
you can get some benefit to that we've
actually found surprising amounts of
success using instantaneous sensor
feedback though so that's kind of
interesting okay so the big picture here
is you have some complicated high
dimensional nonlinear system that you
want to control you don't want to put a
lot of effort into modeling it so
instead what you do is this kind of
exploratory control optimization using
this very very powerful genetic
programming control framework and
there's other optimizations you can run
you can there's other optimizations you
can run to optimize this this cost
functional but genetic programming is
particularly flexible and powerful for
identifying new structures of
controllers that you haven't seen before
okay so next time we'll see how this
works on some fluids experiments and
we'll talk a little bit more about the
practicalities thank you